[Música]
a
escala en parís braulio modo
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español alrededor de dos millones de
personas exiliadas es el saldo
preliminar de la guerra que rusia
declaró a ucrania un saldo que podría
incrementarse considerablemente si esta
guerra se prolonga según diversos
analistas se trata del desplazamiento
más importante que se ha producido en
europa desde la guerra en yugoslavia en
los años 90 o al inicio de la segunda
guerra mundial para hablarnos de este
tema de esos miles de exiliados de esas
personas anónimas que son obligadas de
dejar sus hogares saludamos aquí en
nuestros estudios a delfín díaz
historiadora profesora de la universidad
de pensión payne y autora del libro en
exile el exilio la historia del siglo 18
de euros exiliados en europa hasta
nuestros días del fin días bienvenida a
esta escala en parís buenos días gracias
por acompañarnos las imágenes que están
circulando alrededor de todo el mundo de
esos miles de exiliados de esos miles de
personas anónimas recuerdan los momentos
más oscuros de la historia europea sí sí
hasta dos millones de exiliados han
huido de ucrania desde el inicio de la
guerra y este es el éxodo más brutal
masivo desde el fin de la segunda guerra
mundial sí claro o sea esta guerra que
ocurre a las puertas de la unión europea
está cambiando también en esta visión de
las migraciones forzadas porque hay una
visión más positiva de estas migraciones
más positiva de la que ha prevalecido
durante los últimos años esta guerra de
nuclear ya está generando un doble
sentimiento un seguimiento del rechazo
muy considerable y justificado un
respecto al gobierno ruso no con resultó
a la población rusa y al mismo tiempo
una gran simpatía si se puede llamar así
hacia la población ucraniana esos
desplazados pero como usted menciona en
su libro en todas las guerras que ha
vivido europa los exiliados siempre han
sido un arma política
si hay una una ola de simpatía de
solidaridad transnacional para los
exiliados ucranianos
y nos hace reflexionar sobre esta
acogida de los refugiados y este las
formas de rechazo que pueden que pueden
afectarlos y si miramos si miramos la
historia del continente europeo vemos
que hubo otros episodios durante los
cuales los exiliados fueron objeto de
representaciones ambivalentes muy
valientes porque a la vez negativas
porque el refugiado representaba un y
representa una amenaza una amenaza
política una amenaza para la nación y a
la vez el refugiado representa también
una postura que hacía heroica y ahora yo
pienso que estos exiliados ucranianos y
también hay muchas mujeres entre esos
exiliados
bueno
bueno representan a estas figuras casi
heroicas del del exilio arrancado de sus
hogares arrancados sin lugares de
nacimiento antes del 24 de febrero el
inicio de la guerra con ucrania en
europa veríamos viendo una serie de
disposiciones que se estaban aplicando
precisamente contra los exiliados contra
los refugiados elpresidente macrón
francia que ocupa actualmente la
presidencia de la unión europea incluso
había previsto modificar las leyes al
respecto para endurecer aún más esta
situación sí sí sí quería proteger aún
más las fronteras exteriores de unión
europea y me parece que va que va a
revisar
su programa en materia de de
reforzamiento de la de las fronteras
exteriores de la unión europera o sea
que pueden cambiar la agresiva de
cambiar de manera favorable si ésta está
ya cambiando este
esta manera de considerar la apertura y
la
apertura de las fronteras orientales de
la unión europea una veladora doha que
vemos precisamente con este conflicto es
que países notablemente del este
en particular hungría o polonia radical
abiertamente opuestos a la llegada de
inmigrantes ahora son los que están
recibiendo esos cientos de miles que
vienen procedentes de ucrania
si hay un verdadero cambio de rumbo con
estos países y en materia de acogida de
los exiliados y eso no si eso muestra
también la construcción racial religiosa
y cultural del refugiado y del exiliado
aceptable o incluso deseable
claro porque estos iniciados que están
recibiendo en hungría en polonia no es
gente que venga de áfrica gente que
venga de medio oriente si son los
esclavos son si los europeos propiamente
dichos si esta solidaridad religiosa y
cultural si está muy
importante para justificar esta apertura
de las fronteras orientales desde el
siglo 18 si europa ha estado
recurrentemente inmersa en periodos de
guerras con cientos de miles de
desplazados las migraciones esos
desplazamientos han ido transformando la
imagen de la sociedad hemos percibido
que se desplaza con los percibidos que
como lo percibe
pero hay una cosa que me interesa citar
del del libro que usted ha publicado que
insisto es un libro verdaderamente
erudito en la materia y dice usted lo
siguiente la recepción de los exiliados
extranjeros sobre el continente
continente europeo su llegada se
enfrenta a los temores de las sociedades
de acogida con partidos entre un impulso
de la solidaridad y al mismo tiempo la
tentación de repliegue incluso xenófobo
hoy la figura del refugiado más que
nunca está bajo el carácter de una
sospecha dice usted si este libro trata
de explorar la historia contemporánea
del exilio en europa y desde europa
desde el siglo 18 hasta hasta 2020 y
trata de mostrar esta esta
ambivalencia alrededor de la figura del
refugiado porque hay el cliché del falso
refugiado que se aprovecharía del asilo
para una inmigración totalmente
diferente y este cliché si se observa en
el siglo 19
es muy antiguo y ya en el siglo 19
también hubo momentos de rechazo incluso
xenófobo a los refugiados y a los
extranjeros en general y especialmente
durante las crisis económicas del siglo
19 por ejemplo en
1848 y también a finales del siglo 19
pero a la vez hay también una manera de
considerar al exilio como una figura
heroica y yo recuerdo que el siglo
19 es el exilio de los exiliados y que
para los oponentes para los liberales
para los patriotas el exilio era casi
una necesidad para construir una lucha
política y una lucha política para
también los republicanos o los
demócratas y no olvidemos por ejemplo la
figura del poeta francés víctor hugo que
que cristalizó esta imagen del refugiado
que está existiendo ciertamente es la
gente que se oponía al sistema a las las
coronas a los reyes y que tenga que
salir efectivamente fuera irlanda fuera
la gran bretaña gran bretaña fue un gran
centro de recepción de exiliados a
alemania en su momento ahora bien la
primera guerra mundial cambió la
situación de evidentemente la segunda
guerra mundial generó como consecuencia
más de entre 50 y 60 millones de
refugiados lo que usted comenta en su
libro es el exilio más grande que nunca
antes haya vivido europa el mundo como
tal que resultados destacan en términos
diríamos de el rechazo o de acogida a
esas personas
bueno ya durante el siglo 19 la cuestión
de los refugiados era una preocupación
diplomática mayor pero con la primera
guerra mundial tenemos una primera
construcción de un derecho internacional
que
que protege la figura del refugiado bajo
la
bajo la acción de la sociedad y naciones
en ginebra y luego con la segunda guerra
mundial hay un cambio cuantitativo
cuando este archivo con los 50 millones
de personas refugiadas
expulsadas deportadas y estas personas
no no eran bien acogidas en la
postguerra porque hay que decir que en
1948 el 45 no puso fin en absoluto a los
movimientos de masas de desplazados y de
exiliados y por ejemplo hubo un rechazo
importante en austria o en alemania en
contra de los
desplazados personal personas
desplazadas pero eran refugiados en
realidad la situación fue creciendo con
el tiempo evidentemente hubo leyes que
fueron aprobadas tanto después de la
primera guerra mundial como después de
la segunda guerra mundial damos un salto
importante porque suponemos que europa
había entrado en un largo periodo de paz
si se puede decir de estabilidad
económica y sin embargo sucede que a
partir de los años del fin de los años
ochentas
y la caída del muro de berlín va a
generar también un desplazamiento enorme
de poblaciones que vienen de europa del
este hacia el occidente la disolución de
la unión soviética asimismo el fin días
si durante los años 80 la tasa de
concesión del estatuto de refugiado el
estatuto de la convención de ginebra
se tendió a disminuir de manera brutal
en toda europa y esto lo podemos
relacionar con las circunstancias de la
crisis económica que afectaba a europa y
también esto era consecuencia de la
diversificación de las orígenes
geográficas de los exiliados porque en
este en aquel momento llegaron a europa
muchísimos exiliados de asia y de áfrica
y esto cambiaba la percepción del
exiliado porque el exiliado ya no se
podría relacionar con la figura la
figura del disidente soviets soviético
que está que estaba muy bien acogido en
europa occidental y la figura del
refugiado estaba cambiando y esta tasa
de concesión disminuyó
si hay una transición un giro muy
importante en estos años a mi parecer de
manera breve qué es lo que hace que
usted hable de una transición
precisamente entre lo que fueron los
años 80 y la situación que se vive a
partir de los años 90 2000 concretamente
de manera breve a partir de los años
2000 hubo también la la consecuencia de
las revoluciones que se conocieron como
la primera la primavera árabe y esto
también
modificó mucho la percepción de los
exiliados con la multiplicación de las
devoluciones en las fronteras los
famosos e ilegales pues bucks en las
fronteras europeas
y en este momento hay una selectividad
muy importante del asilo en europa y una
selectividad que se nota ahora también
con la guerra de eeuu cara de ucrania en
contraste una situación que sin duda va
a acentuarse con el paso de las semanas
de los meses esta guerra parece haber
llegado para quedarse durante un buen
tiempo vamos a ver cuáles son las
respuestas que podrán dar los distintos
gobiernos sean moscú sea en ucrania sean
notablemente los gobiernos europeos
estamos llegando ya al final de esta
escala en parís
yo quisiera agradecerle a delfín díaz
historiadora profesora de historia
precisamente de la universidad de ransa
ya en champagne ardenne su participación
y me permito recomendar a aquellos que
hablen en francés este excelente libro
que se llama en exile de los refugiados
en europa del final del siglo 18 hasta
nuestros días publicado por ediciones
folio muchas gracias delfín muchísimas
gracias a ustedes les damos una nueva
cita aquí la próxima semana en otra
escala en parís
[Música]